y nos piden que calculemos la suma de
los primeros 50 términos de esta serie y
tal vez inmediatamente reconozcan que es
una serie geométrica entonces cuando
pasamos de un término a otro que es lo
que estamos haciendo bueno al pasar de 1
a 10 onceavos multiplicamos por 10 entre
11 y después volvemos a multiplicar por
10 entre 11 y así sucesivamente
entonces como necesitamos encontrar los
primeros 50 términos podemos aplicar la
fórmula que deducimos anteriormente para
la suma de series geométricas finitas
que dice que la suma de en este caso de
los primeros 50 términos la suma de los
primeros 50 términos es igual al primer
término que en este caso es 1 es igual a
1 x vamos a ponerlo de otro color
por 1 - la razón común que en este caso
es 10 11 a vos
10 11 a vos a la 50 es decir al número
de términos que tenemos y todo eso entre
1 - nuestra razón común ahora no voy a
resolverlo completamente pero podemos
simplificar esto un poco esto es igual a
1 menos a olvide poner el paréntesis
aquí ahora si uno menos 10 onceavos a la
50 entre esto es 11 onceavos menos 10
onceavos eso es igual a 1 entre 11 que
es lo mismo que multiplicar el numerador
por 11 entonces esto es igual a 11
por 1 menos 10 11 a vos a las 50 ok y
podríamos tratar de simplificar esto aún
más pero hasta aquí está bien porque en
este punto todo esa aritmética hagamos
otro es divertido vamos a ver claramente
esta es una serie geométrica pero
primero veamos cuántos términos tenemos
y tal vez piensen bueno si al final está
elevado a la potencia 79 han de ser 79
términos pero tengan cuidado porque el
primer término empieza desde que
elevamos a la potencia cero es decir en
el primer término restamos 0.99 a la
cero en el segundo término estamos
elevando a la potencia 1 el tercer
término lo elevamos al cuadrado y el
cuarto término está elevado al cubo y
así sucesivamente entonces este término
es el número 80
este es el término número 80
entonces si nosotros queremos encontrar
ese subíndice 80 esto es igual a nuestro
primer término que es uno por uno menos
la razón común elevada a la 80 y todo
eso entre estoy dejando ese espacio en
blanco porque aún no sabemos cuál es
nuestra razón común entre 1 - la razón
como ahora al principio tal vez me digan
pues no tal vez aquí la razón común sea
0.99 pero observen que aquí tenemos un
cambio de signo así que para pasar de un
término al siguiente porque lo
multiplicamos bueno para pasar del
primer término al segundo multiplicamos
por menos 0.99 entonces multiplicamos
por menos 0.99 y para el siguiente
terminó nuevamente multiplicamos por
menos 0.99 así que nuestra razón común
no es 0.99 positivo sino
- 0.99 vamos a escribir menos 0.99 y
claro esto elevado a la 80 entre 1 menos
menos 0.99 ahora vamos a simplificar
esto un poco todo esto es igual a bueno
no necesitamos preocuparnos por este uno
entonces nos queda uno menos menos 0.99
elevado a la 80 y bueno como estamos
elevando a un número par esto será
positivo
entonces nos queda como 0.99 a la 80 y
todo eso entre menos y menos es más
entonces todo esto entre 1.99 y
podríamos simplificar esto aún más pero
si tenemos una calculadora podemos
encontrar el valor exacto o mejor dicho
el valor más aproximado porque la
mayoría de las calculadoras no nos dan
el valor exacto
cuando elevamos salgo a la 80 pero bueno
esta es nuestra suma hagamos otro aquí
tenemos una serie definida recursiva
mente y es muy útil pensar en cómo se ve
miren el primer término es 10 y después
el siguiente término vamos a ver el
segundo término es decir a subíndice 2
es igual a a subíndice 1 por 9 decimos
entonces el siguiente término es igual
al término anterior por 9 decimos
entonces es igual a 10 por 9 entre 10 y
el siguiente término es igual al segundo
término por 9 decimos entonces 10 por 9
entre 10 al cuadrado
pero de esta forma no está escrito como
una serie geométrica finita entonces
digamos que queremos la suma la suma de
los primeros no sé de los primeros 30
términos queremos la suma de los
primeros 30 términos entonces como sería
bueno estamos buscando ese subíndice 30
entonces la suma de los primeros 30
términos es igual a el primer término
por uno menos la razón común elevada a
la 30 y todo eso entre uno menos la
razón común entonces uno menos nueve
décimos es undécimo dividimos entre un
décimo y eso es lo mismo a que si
multiplicamos por 100 entonces esto es
igual a 100 por uno menos nueve decimos
elevado a la 30
elevamos a la 30 los 9 décimos no
solamente el número 9 pues bueno ahí lo
tiene